i think you could reinvent toastmasters
um like i feel like this is a business i
could start if i wanted to which is like
toastmasters i think can be
modernized like you don't have to have
the oversized suit you don't need the
like in-person meetups like i wrote
discord toastmasters like i think you
could do this whole thing and zoom or
discord
like i think you just have people get
into little chapters
practice this stuff make you know they
kind of meet people they kind of learn
some techniques and they kind of get
over their stage fight around public
speaking and the local ones ladder up
into like the state ones they ladder up
into like the national ones and some
people compete at it um and you get your
certificate after going through the
program and it's like kind of a course
it's kind of a church and it's kind of
like a self-help seminar um
that i think could be recreated in a
modern way using discord that's my idea
react to that
[Music]
all right what up
it's my first million
to podcast
that will
change your goddamn life
if you like your life unsubscribe right
now because it ain't staying the same by
the end of this listen to that again
that's a good
tagline all right um
by the way i think of all these amazing
intros when we're not here uh on the pod
and then i totally forget to do them
like last night i was like i was doing
this little train sound to my daughter
and i'm i was like dude i'm freakishly
good at making this train sound i am
like the best at doing this fake trade i
was like i gotta show sam i'm just gonna
start the podcast feel like sam you
wanna hear a train sound and then i'm
gonna do it ready
[Laughter]
this is the stupidest [__] ever
listen to this a great cold open
uh all right dude talk to me about this
dude who emailed us this guy who's this
guy all right so so jonathan was like
hey you guys got to announce the winners
for the clip contest and i don't know
who they are but he's going to help us
do it
is it
jonathan is it this guy dylan or can i
tell a separate story about this guy i i
don't know who dylan is
okay all right so this guy is a winner
in my heart he may not have won the
contest but i'm going to find a way to
like employ this person because he's
amazing so this guy reaches out
um i'm just gonna read you the cold
email because it was too good he goes
sounds like a random letter
yeah i felt a little unsafe
it goes i've clipped every mfm youtube
pod that has been released just
all business straight to the end there
he goes hey sam and sean then again in
all bold i've clipped every mfm podcast
episode you've ever released i'm 22
unemployed i'm moving to israel next
month and i have nothing to lose just
kidding he didn't have that nothing to
lose part but that [__] would have been
a little dangerous
um he says i have nothing but 7k in
savings
to avoid getting a job in israel i
figured i'd clip a
clip all of your podcasts and either a
you'll you'll buy my clips channel or b
you'll hire me to do this for you full
time
you keep saying that you want to grow
your youtube channel but you're not
you're simply not putting on enough
content let me explain
youtube shorts short viewers are
addicted to crack cocaine
youtube wants to give viewers as much
crack cocaine as possible to keep them
addicted to youtube your content is the
crack cocaine and crack cocaine addicts
don't care about quality they care about
quantity the amount of crack
and he goes uh here's what you can do
you're gonna use youtube shorts to drive
people to your main channel your main
content is quality your shorts are gonna
be quality
hire a dog parentheses me which is just
just an incredible way to start a
sentence hire a dog parenthesis me
to pump out 100 shorts a day get an
average of 600 000 new monthly viewers
that will come from the youtube
discovery feed what's and then he goes
this is the ransom letter party guys
what's 600 000 new monthly viewers worth
to you
question mark your dog dylan that's
right dylan you are my dog man this is
amazing this is an amazing email spoke
straight to my heart i emailed him i did
you i replied separately did you no i
just forwarded it to everybody i afford
it to my whole team i was like this
guy's a dog and then we and then he put
a clip in there he goes here's an
unlisted video from the account to prove
it to me and then you watch it and he's
talking and he sounds normal and he's
cool and he's interesting and i was like
i freaking love this guy i know i
emailed him i was like hey um i i'm
going to send your stuff to hubspot and
they could decide what they want to do
with this but like can i hire you to do
stuff because you told me you hired this
content person i was like i probably
need i've kind of been sucking on my
personal [__] maybe i should hire this
guy and i emailed him so i'm definitely
going to talk to him uh he this was a
really good email i ignored just about
every single email but this one i
replied and i was like so dylan i
haven't replied yet but you're gonna get
something from both of us or one of us i
don't know um jonathan you had some more
logistical things to say about who
actually won the contest who who won the
contest
so we do
not win by the way wait and well let's
say so we do a contest
where we give 5 000 so basically we have
like these full episodes on youtube
people go there they clap clip them up
and they post them on tik tok and
instagram whatever they use our hashtag
and we just are going to select people
and we give them five grand but go ahead
jonathan yeah so you select we select
one person who has the most views period
and then the other one is just the
person of our choosing so dylan you are
the lucky winner it sounds like uh but
the actual winner was just some dude who
created a tick tock with neil patel and
it said like this billionaire spends
100k which is not even true because he's
not a billionaire uh so that is the
other winner that person's channel is
called
how many views did that get
that
yeah my first
my first milk clip
how do these like there's so many kids
that are doing this they put on tick
tock how do they get so many views well
this guy guy's a genius because he took
he took the right clip right so he took
a clip of some guy saying how much he
spends which is
gonna go viral because people get mad
about it um people get mad when they
hear somebody spending so much money and
talking about it so casually because he
also says in the clip you know i'm not
rich but blah blah blah and then people
are like yeah you're not rich bro you
spend 180k a month and they like go off
and so that little thing is like a
trigger and it's like oh watch this i'll
trigger everybody right now with this
one little clip so i think that's what
worked also in the comments he was smart
because somebody would comment be like
who is this guy or the and he he replied
founder of google question mark like the
the guy so he's intensely replying the
wrong thing and everyone's like dude
that's not the founder of google so all
of a sudden the algorithm's like yes
comments
comments and so he would just reply like
um
like nonsense [__] to people's comments
and then people would be like you're
wrong dude you're so wrong he's like yes
but i'm about to win this five grand off
this two million view clip so you know
congrats but also guys i feel like we
should
right now they're all making their own
handles like
mfm clip
you know million clip boys and like they
all have their own little handle like
shouldn't we get these people it's only
like i don't know 10 people who are
really good at this like could we get
them behind like our actual clips
channel and be like whoever within this
channel gets the most views gets the
bounty for the month how do you do that
you just you're going to give the
password and login to 10 different
people and just say like fight yeah
it's like you just like we're it's like
we're just going to throw like one yeah
a [__] fighting uh
event i'm down
can we is that able to be pulled off
like can you how do you know whose is
whose
but they
put them in a slack and give them all
the login and then when they post it's
like they have to say i posted x
and then you're like all right cool jump
up put it in the spreadsheet which one
you posted and then we'll keep track
can we do that that actually that's
great let's just do that it'll also make
it easier for all of them because then
that account will have more content so
then all of them will benefit from the
additional
juice the followers that builds up will
all be aggregated and we will own the
channel in the end which is helpful to
us and so i feel like that's a better
way to go sounds like dylan's the dog so
we just put dylan to work and he should
be able to dylan you know like in any
good uh you know like cockfight uh you
know two chickens or roosters or
whatever fighting each other it's like
there's the one who's got like one eye
he's been through like a hundred fights
and he's still here so that's dylan the
dog and every new challenger kind of
comes in and he kind of wrangles them
and you know keeps them all together
that's how i'm viewing this
i'm i'm about it anyone that calls
himself a dog i think is pretty cool
uh so
i'm a simple man with simple taste yeah
like well i only know like dog the
bounty hunter but he's cool to me so
this guy dillon the dog is
the we're two for two for cool dogs
[Laughter]
your name's got an alliteration sweet i
mean
let's see no more
where do we go from here
all right um well let's talk about this
content remixer thing so i posted this
on twitter i think this is kind of what
you were talking about i was like hey
man i produce a bunch of content but
like
i'm kind of lazy with the follow up so
you know i'll produce the content of
this podcast but as soon as we like
literally the podcast ends with usually
you say
all right we're done that's the episode
and then
literally it's usually like one second
later i'm like i realize how hungry i am
i'm like i'm gonna go eat bye and then
we like don't talk again until the next
you know dude i don't even know
i just i had to like you and i recorded
today's wednesday recorded on monday i
like messaged ben on tuesday i'm like
why aren't the episodes out and he goes
like uh because we release it like next
week i'm like we do since when it's like
always last february yeah
like
i don't know how this podcast goes on
the internet
so yeah we were even when i almost never
or like the other day i like clicked it
in the in the app and i was like oh man
like this description is horribly out of
date and this title and this intro and i
like sent ben all these notes and he's
probably like dude we've been doing it
this way for like if you had a problem
with this why did you say anything for
the last nine months and it's like i
don't know i never listen i never click
it like i'm here for the live show i
don't i don't go to it after the fact uh
it takes up a lot of space on my phone
in fact i delete all the episodes
so you know i'm not really the the right
listener but anyways long story short i
put out this tweet i said hey
i want to hire a content remixer
basically i put out content
on a podcast or our newsletter from
milkroad but that's content that could
live that could be turned into tweets
turned into linkedin posts and like
it seems like that's what smart people
do they like cross-post their [__] at
other places like we're we're doing
contests so that somebody else will take
our clips and put it on tiktok um so
this is this idea of content remixing
and i got a bunch of people interested
which was great i hired one guy this guy
brandon
and he started with me this week and
he's already putting out like already
this week i'm gonna put out more content
than i did like the last six months
because he's like all he's doing is
taking the best stuff we've already done
and just like packaging it into smaller
nuggets that can go on all these
different places
so like for example i'm adding a
newsletter send once a week that's just
gonna take the three best ideas or
topics we talked about on the pod i'm
just gonna compile them into that
because i know those people like people
who are on my newsletter they would like
this content summarized and maybe even
fleshed out right because the podcast is
very off the cuff so sometimes you could
kind of trim the fat and do a little
extra research add a little data um and
make it even better and so just take the
three best things we talked about
so he's doing that for milk road he's
putting we put it on linkedin we put on
twitter it's like okay cool so there's
this idea of content remixing and as i
was doing it i saw a bunch of other
people were like hey if you find anyone
good i would happily pay for this i'm
you know i'm i'm already like you know
up to my ears and like how much content
i'm willing to create and like i would
love it if somebody just took my stuff
and repurposed it for other platforms
who's an example of someone who reaches
out
so um oh god who's their names so i'll
show you uh actually the guy who used to
work for you alex garcia i think is this
yeah yeah yeah
um so he had tweeted out something very
similar he's like you gotta recycle your
content
um
and a bunch of people had replied into
that as well
uh so that's that's where i had seen oh
wow there's like i'm not just getting
emails about it but like people publicly
were also like i would uh i would pay
for this if you had this uh here we go
so
uh this guy
i don't know how you say his name kai
kai hai i don't know he's got this
famous blog radreads.com yeah yeah yeah
can you say this guy's name
i don't know it's one of those words
that i have only read on paper and i'm
too embarrassed to say it out loud
so he's probably got like you know i
don't know tens of thousands of 100 000
subscribers he goes he goes man how
would i find train and manage this
person like let me know if you find it
another guy kp says dude this is so true
i need one for my newsletter another
person comes in and they're like um
who was like somebody who's in the like
kind of buying businesses space and they
were like yeah i would kill for one of
these and so i started thinking like
actually i've been noticing there's
these like niche agencies
that people create that are like
this like productized service so it's a
service that they turn into like
hey you need an exec assistant like just
come to us we have vetted trained exec
assistants that we will assign to you
and we'll kind of manage that
relationship and make sure that you you
learn how to use them and they provide
great service to you and you're not like
you don't have to find them you don't
have to train them you don't have to
worry about quality control and so like
i think athena is one of those that's
like big and they're like tech circles
uh our buddy jack i think uses one of
theirs we talked about the and we have
like right away our friend
uh marshall does shepherd is it called
separate shepherd support yeah and they
like scale pretty quickly um it's just a
service-based business it's very
straightforward
my buddy jesse puji he did one called
growth assistant it's pretty dope
basically it's like hey there's people
like in the philippines that are really
good at like managing your facebook ads
reporting data in excel like every day
um you know like going and updating your
seo tags and [__] like that like all
these like little things that help your
business grow so he took the idea of
like a va or a an executive assistant he
just rebranded it as a growth assistant
and specifically they know how to do
tasks that are related to growth um like
oh i'll go get a transcript made and
then i'll format it i'll post it on your
blog or i'll i'll do i'll look up your
analytics and post it to you in slack
every morning you and i have a friend
and they make a million dollars a year
80 000 a month ghost writing tweets for
other for like popular people not
popular people but like business people
uh
writing other people's tweets and using
his uh handle to click like on the
tweets that they write so it's traction
and amazing he was this person was
telling me about this and i was like hey
that's awesome and b like if you wanted
to and actually scale this into
something that could potentially make
like four five six million dollars a
year i think you could do i mean just
it's just a boring agency it's not like
that cool but i think you could just do
like a twitter ghostwriting service i
don't actually know how you would do it
because um this person who i mentioned
they do have some help overseas and i
don't actually know how would you do it
how do you teach
how do you teach someone in the
philippines to do this
i think you could teach it but the hard
part is like
if you're gross writing for somebody
else like again you need the source
content from somewhere right like the
thought has to be somewhere so anybody
could write the tweet once you have the
thought like for example you did this
with that what's his name the hockey
player you helped like go super viral
like five times
uh chris so
chris pronger he had but dude that was
like the easiest thing because i'm like
well you're like you've made over a
hundred million dollars in the nhl like
this is the easiest thing ever it's like
you still like that this is an
interesting story yeah well it's like a
hot chick asking like for dating advice
it's like oh i mean it's like like this
is the easiest game on earth right
you know you got instagram tips for me
yeah like move the camera down three
inches
yeah it's just like the easiest you know
what i mean like they he he had the
goods you know like yeah it was easy
that's an easy game i don't know how you
would do that though for someone who's
just a computer nerd well i think people
do it for companies right i think that's
where he that's where that that friend
is doing it they basically take
companies i think that they invest in
and then they upsell them this service
for their company content i think that's
for them for the uh like the ceos
yeah yeah exactly and so they they kind
of whatever i don't know but i'm
interested in these like productized
service agencies i think they can do
well i bet you i i'm i don't want to do
this so like you know feel free to steal
my idea of like content remixers
um there's all this already exists for
like you know we cut clips of your
youtube videos i'm not saying this
doesn't exist i'm just saying dude a lot
of pretty sure this would be successful
a lot of people are doing this right now
for clips so you and i know a couple
people like that guy michael who uh you
met with the other day and then uh what
was the guys names who we hired like two
years ago to do dylan and henry yeah yes
uh and that's like fine i think tax is
way easier like way easier like because
the market is better
because podcasters are not a good market
to sell to they don't have this type of
stuff they're not making any money off
this right um
so you need to go for somebody who
already has money and just has a
shortage of time um and for them words
that bring them attention
becomes
uh you know becomes more money right how
much that's the trick how much did you
pay this guy uh you probably don't want
to say i don't want to say i already
said his name
but you know whatever it's a reasonable
amount so uh but but i would say if you
want to see kind of how these work that
guy jesse uh jesse puji on twitter
he tweets out the numbers behind his
agency every like month or two and so
like they're now up to 500 i think 500
000 a month in monthly recurring revenue
um 400 or 500 000. there's a woman named
adrian who actually runs the company so
he had the idea
he had a friend or somebody he'd worked
with in the past named adrian she
start actually like is the ceo of that
company and it's called assistant and
growth assistant basically just means
like they fill out they just they fill
out like spreadsheets
it's kind of like all the little junior
growth hacky assistant stuff so like
i'll tell you how we use it for ecom
right uh or like
we don't use them but like here's what i
would do i i kind of like this is this
is for somebody who's not as experienced
maybe because like i already had
people like this set up so i didn't need
to pay the additional
like fee that you you know you have to
pay this management company right but uh
basically i'm like hey every day
you go put you go take all the uh these
five kpis from our facebook ads google
ads and shopify you put them in this
spreadsheet you color code it
then you take a screenshot you put that
in slack because i want to wake up in
the morning and i want to see our
numbers color coded and i want to be
able to comment on it and take action i
don't want to spend the hour right like
digging through and updating this
dashboard and then secondly it's like oh
okay cool every week i want you to go
take the top sellers i want you to
reorganize the store based on these
rules and it's like i'm sure there's
some software app that can kind of do
this but like for for every business
there's all these little nuanced you
know like sort of like duct tape
together things that you do that just
make it work a little better but
anything that's repetitive and anything
you don't enjoy you want to delegate and
so you delegate that to a growth
assistant you teach them how to do this
like we do it with influencer outreach
too like
go on go to this tool find influencers
who who match this criteria
reach out with this pitch here's the
follow-up sequence i help craft with you
and then like every time they they post
something put it in this google drive
photo so that my ads team can use it
right like it's like super it's like a
pipeline you know of of organization
can you tell me about this ddc soda
stream competitor thing
yeah i think it's a great idea so i got
a soda stream you probably already have
one or have seen dude so listen listen
listen what i have i have a soda stream
okay and then as a gift i was gifted
this thing so a soda stream is basically
uh a canis it's this thing whatever but
you buy like the you have to buy like a
30 canister at the rate i was going like
every uh two or three weeks because i
use it at a time that's like all i drink
it's like 30 bucks so what i did was i
went to a scuba store
and i bought a huge a scuba tank
and it's you if you go to my tick tock
you can see it i bought this huge scuba
tank and that cost uh like 30
uh and i filled it up with uh co2 or
whatever it is and that's what i've been
using to to drink uh for my soda stream
and it's the greatest thing ever you
like i just bought this like this like
this like attachment so i could uh
uh use it it's pretty amazing that's
hilarious dude yeah so i just got one
um and i used to laugh and be like oh
nice home brew you're doing for your
water like jeez you know like
like could you pick a more boring hobby
than like bubbling your own like water
at home dude
check the link that i sent you in the
slack or in the um in the in the
riverside chat
okay let's see
is this your okay it's a tick tock of
your uh oh my god this is hilarious it's
a giant scuba tank on the ground
hooked up wired to your soda stream
is this not going to be like too high
powered
it makes it it's very high powered i
like i like what i say at home is i want
my bubbles to be aggressive
i want i want i want i really thought
your quote there was going to be cooler
yeah
i say at home i i always tell people i
like my water bubbly
yeah
but i do like aggressive bubbles like
you know toppo chico i want it like how
it burns so good that's what i want and
uh yeah there you go
and and that's what i want so anyway i
did that i bought like a piece for it
for like ten dollars like it converts a
scuba tank into a canister for toe uh
for these soda streams this soda stream
business do you know that it's like a
multi-billion dollar product
yeah that's what i was gonna bring up so
i when i bought this i was like
i was like this is a great idea you know
i'm buying tons of lacroix and stuff
like that it's kind of annoying go like
these heavy can things i was like
actually this does make sense to do at
home
and
the product is slick you don't plug it
like i thought oh i'm gonna have to like
connect this to my water line or
something like that it's like no it's
like just sits on your counter
no attachments it's like [__]
hands-free wireless bluetooth got it's
like an airpod basically and you put the
bottle in you pump it three times you
feel like you feel like you did it so
you get this like sense of
accomplishment and then you get the
fresh sparkling water and it's awesome
and it's not even flavored but it's fine
and my daughter loves making it with me
it's like a whole activity i can like if
she's crying i'm like you want to go
make some spicy water and she's like yes
and so then we go and do it and so i'm
like all right this is an amazing thing
i go look it up i'm like you know i
think this soda stream could be big and
then like of course i'm the idiot i go
google it's like it sold for three
billion dollars like i don't know five
years ago or something like that like
it's owned by pepsi i think they
probably do a billion in revenue i'm
pretty sure right before they sold they
were at 900 something million in annual
revenue and then they sold in like you
haven't heard numbers since and like i'm
sure it's over a billion dollars now
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm pretty sure so
there's two businesses in this space
that i was shocked at how big they are
and one was sodastream i think it's an
israeli company correct like i'm just
this is off member i don't remember it
yes i believe so it's an israeli company
that has been around for a bit and they
killed it them and you know what else is
just a behemoth is courage curd coffee
uh i think curry coffee makes uh like
five or ten or something crazy billion
dollars a year in revenue and it's been
parlayed into a holding company uh that
they buy all types of other stuff
right oh wow um yeah the other one
that's like this i thought you were
going to say is what's the name of the
one that was in
offices
and i think this is it
i think it's bevvy yeah bbv
wire i'm not sure exactly which one um
that was a multi-hundred million maybe a
billion dollar company also and
basically it was like hey
fancy water fountain for your office
like
you can bring your water bottle to this
you can uh just take a cup it can do
bubbling it could do flat it could do
warm and it's like
all right that's cool that's better than
like and i think they give you the
machine for free and then you've got to
like just pay for the canisters over
time right it's the same like razor
blade model i'm like a big soda guy like
to the point of sometimes i go when i
lived in san francisco i used to go to
this movie theater nearby because they
had a freestyle coke machine that you
could use without buying a ticket to the
movie so i always i would always walk
there just to get a cherry vanilla coke
zero out of the soda machine the
freestyle machine you know those
machines of course of course they're the
best so i try to buy one
and
you can't you can't buy a you can't buy
one of those machines you have to lease
it in their terms it's like a lifetime
lease so you have to spend like i think
like 200 a month and you have to be
willing to sign like this crazy
agreement and then they have to come
every month to refill the thing it was a
pain in the ass i was like dude i just
want like a like i want like a coke
fountain
like this seems like pretty easy just
let me give you money and have it
and you you couldn't you couldn't do it
so these bevvy machines i'm all about i
think they're amazing and the soda the
soda stream i think is also amazing i
have one and i use it all the time too
but i i hate going to bed bath and
beyond buying those stupid-ass
containers
right and so i think that there there
are but i think that they're you i'm
sure some of these are successful but
basically i saw it i was like this would
make for a really interesting dc product
because i think you could this has the
makings of what would make a really good
ddc product and then i found one that
was like really well designed i can't
find the name of it right now it's like
cell neck or some cell deck or something
i don't know what it was
something like that but basically
sodastream competitor but you just say
all right these guys are selling through
target and whatever how can i
do the normal d2c playbook right get the
logo lowercase pastel fonts send it to
some influencers create a juicy offer
that's like you know you can get the
machine for like just pay for shipping
and i'll send you the machine and then
like now you're on the hook for the
subscription of like cartridges
uh someone's like someone's been reading
book
make it small make it big do something
to like to make it add a twist to it but
damn this thing could uh
this thing could work this thing could
pop off so i don't know ddc sodastream
competitor i think that's like a 100
million dollar plus idea yeah that's an
easy one what else do you want to do
um all right let me give you another
thing that i think is kind of cool so
i started teaching my course this week
and um how'd it go is it bigger you know
i make it i make it look easy bro i make
it look easy
i heard people showed up shirtless
yeah there's multiple people who just
come to the class without the shirt on
and i'm like
bold bold choice
um
make yourself at home
and uh you know they're all like ripped
so like you know
it's not like
like we do have a line and the line is
if you're not ripped
[Laughter]
if you're not adding to the visual
appeal you're taking it away from the
visual appeal and that's where the rule
with michael my class are my rules
we're the
sales where the sales uh how do they
compare to the
is digital revenue dropping off
highest sales ever
really
for me i thought it would be slower
because like the economy's going down
i don't know why maybe uh maybe i sold
it better maybe people just were like oh
you know what like yeah
life is changing you got pandemic you
got layoffs you got all kinds of stuff
like what if you know basically can i
use a skill set here to like to like win
in this like what do i need to change
given that the world is like not the
same as it was i think there's an
element of that like it's sort of a new
year's resolution effect where when the
world changes a bunch people like assess
like what's what matters and they
realize like oh wow if i invested a
little bit of money here could i unlock
more potential than this new path
because my current path is being shaken
up and you did it on maven what's the
reason no maven
they've been like they went overboard
for me it's been awesome so they're like
they're like managing my course for me
and like doing a bunch of awesome help
helpful stuff
the first session i was like oh [__]
okay i gotta like dust off the cobwebs i
gotta go perform
and right before i was like okay i'm
gonna go on and i always work myself
into a state a state of mind
and i'm like i'm gonna i don't i don't
show up to these like cold
or i don't rely on the slide deck or the
material like i gotta perform so i'm
like
but
but i'm like it's ten minutes before and
i'm like oh i'm not in state right now i
gotta get and say so i'm like okay what
do i do and i'm like i gotta like you
know like in nascar or whatever you pull
over and like they do like the pit stop
and like like
take off all four wheels put new wheels
on they're like paint again slap the
driver in the face like go like that's
basically what i did to myself i like
jumped in a cold shower and i like
i like immediately uh turned on this
thing i was like i like this like
youtube video and i was like what do i
need i was like i was like i think if i
come out hot with a story like i think
in that first two minutes if i just come
in strong people are going to be like oh
[__] this is going to be an up like this
is going to be different like oh this is
going to be good because you know like
that first impression is going to really
matter so i googled this like um i was
like amazing i don't know what i wrote
but i was like amazing
uh
start of a speech i put that in youtube
or something and it pops out this video
from a guy who won like the toastmasters
challenge and the guy does this he goes
this is good for the youtube viewers uh
maybe podcast you're not gonna know what
the hell is going on so
the guy walks out on stage not a not a
great looking guy some you know looks
like my indian cousin from somewhere so
he he walks out and he's like
doesn't say a word
stands in front of the stage
he's digging into his pocket you don't
know what he's reaching for
pulls out a cigarette puts it in his
teeth
gets a lighter
kind of like the cigarette
and and you could just hear the crowd
like murmuring like some people are
laughing nervously some people are like
no like you're indoors like
don't do this and like other people are
just like they don't know what to make
of it so already
[__] has to said a word and he's
commanding the room
just by doing a pattern interrupt right
so he comes out here and he's like
and he looks at the crowd because
they're all reacting at this point and
he was like in his own world
and he didn't come out there say hi i'm
sean i'm here to talk about but no no he
didn't go out there and grovel to the
audience he's
he's trying to like to say right then he
looks like oh you're there and he he
looks and he goes
what
this
no
and i was like what i was like what is
he doing this is incredible this is mind
blowing he's so he's like in just his
facial expression he was like oh what
what am i doing this
no he goes you think this is gonna kill
me
let me tell you something you know how
many people die from cigarettes every
year and i was like and nobody does the
answer he's like whatever four million
people die from cigarettes every year
he's like you know how many people die
from like a obesity from sugar if i had
brought out a cupcake and he's like you
know nobody would have bought an eye but
i like this one little cigarettes
statistically shows that you know like
actually the biggest variable in me
getting lung cancer is my genetics and
not the fact that i smoke a lot he goes
and also i made all those facts up
and then he said that he's like but then
he's got him like in the palm of his
hand they're laughing they're like
they're intrigued everybody's paying
attention then he goes into his talk and
whenever he like starts his thing
and i was like this is the fire i need i
turn off the video i run out the shower
i put on a shirt i start my my course
and i'm like i don't do that i do like a
completely different thing but that just
sort of like set the mood for what did
you do
so what did i do oh i go
um
i sorry i first told the story i go
i go you know i'm here but i normally
don't do this
and they're like
what are you like you're you're teaching
this course i just paid you money what
do you mean you don't so i'm like i
don't want to do this you know i um
i once i wanted to watch what amazing
what does the best public speaker do so
i watched a video of tony robbins
talking at the dream force conference
who here is from san francisco you know
if you're you know the dream force
conference if you're from san francisco
because it shuts the whole [__] city
down and you're like why why can't i
drive because salesforce is having a
conference like they shut down the roads
and people like yeah yeah in the chat
and then i'm like all right and mark
benioff ceo of salesforce goes all right
guys we got a special treat the final
speaker of the event
this guy's one of the best but here's
the deal
he doesn't come out to a cold room
this guy will not come out if this room
is cold he won't and not temperature
wise he's like you need to have some
energy you need to be i know it's the
end of the day but this guy won't walk
out to a cold room so get let's get the
clap going and people start clapping and
he comes out and like it's basically
like he got a standing ovation before he
even entered the stage and i was like i
was like i saw that and i was like hmm
new thing for me i don't come out to a
cold room and so i like demanded that
they give me a little energy and i was
like i was like how about we start with
a story who's down for a story and
they're like hey all right well give me
a story i go and i told a story
i've told it on the podcast before the
dmv story and basically my my message to
them was like look
let's all be honest
uh 98 of courses end in what and
everybody in the chat's like waste of
money waste of time blah blah blah i'm
like so good decision you dropped a
thousand dollars on this course and you
know that the stats say 98 of you are
gonna end up with a waste of money no
results no progress waste of time and i
was like
okay but we don't we don't you know
we're not part of we don't want to be a
statistic so like what's the right way
to do this and i told this story about
like how my trainer how he goes to the
dmv and normally the dmv is like this
horrible experience and he's like i want
a five-star experience so he decided to
show up he's like if i want them to be a
five-star hospitality experience like
the ritz carlton of dmvs i'm gonna show
up as a five-star customer so i'm gonna
walk in with a different energy into
that and then like he and then a bunch
of good things happen he got to skip the
lines lady gave him the thing he didn't
have to take the test blah blah blah i
tell her i told the full story of that
that version and i was basically telling
them like you're gonna get out what you
put in if you show up to this like
yeah half of you are right now in the
zoom slouched over low energy half
checking your phone uh you know not sure
if this is gonna be good or bad like you
know not convinced
you know
you're coming in with a two-star
attitude and a two-star effort you're
gonna get a two-star result and so i'm
gonna show you in this first session
literally how to attend a course it has
nothing to do with writing but i'm going
to teach you how to show up to a course
we don't learn this in school i'm going
to show you how to actually do this
right and then i like go through a
couple of like methods that's actually
it's amazing so you let's talk about
this course thing for a second because
it seems like you are getting a lot of
energy from doing it right right
in the moment yes
i enjoy teaching it i hate selling it
fair okay great
i mean i don't think anyone really
enjoys telling it but i i think you you
you enjoy the the act of teaching which
is good
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients hold history calls
support tickets emails and
here's a test from three days ago i
totally missed
hubspot grow better
so listen to this what i did today is i
uh so i've been doing this thing i i i'm
also gonna be a little vague i'm
starting on this new thing that i'm
working on and i found a company in the
space that recently sold for 2.5 ish
million dollars to a pe firm and um i
found the the partner at the pe firm who
bought it and today i just called them i
just picked the phone and called them
and i go hi uh what's going on uh my
name's sam um
sorry this is weird but do you have like
two minutes to talk do you listen to
podcasts by chance well he goes
he was like well you're sampar right
from my first million i was like
[__] a what's up uh you know who i am
but the reason i'm calling is basically
i'm starting a
business that's a competitor to the one
that you just bought last week and i
wanted to know why you bought that
company and what made it great and uh
what what like what sucked about it uh
he's like whoa you're really like coming
forward you're you know you're being
pretty forward i was like yeah well like
here's the deal like um this is gonna
play out a few ways i'm gonna start this
thing it's gonna fail so you know you
don't have to worry about that uh the
second thing is i'm gonna start
something and i'm just gonna like crush
you guys um and the third way i start
something and you eventually buy us um
but like you know
either way like i'm happy to share what
i'm doing and and hopefully you can
share what you're doing and maybe
somehow we can figure out a way to help
us and i was like i know that sounds
cocky i'm sorry but i this is out of
respect i think you guys are actually
amazing and uh
it was so productive it it i like like
i'm sorry but
um me and dylan we're both dogs and so
a dog like me coming to a dog like you
but this guy he was like
uh he said um
he's like yeah you know like i gotta go
tell the team that like uh you know uh
someone who's launched businesses in the
before who has some capital is going
into our space and i was in my head i
was like i i don't want to do this but i
was like dude i bet you i could sell
this company to this guy right now now
yeah yeah
it's like
i think just
brother you ever heard of addition by
subtraction
i can tell you a little something about
how to get rid of competition right now
if you could do some addition on that
calculator of yours take that bad boy
out let's come up with a number
yeah i was like i was thinking about it
i'm like
am i can i just threaten you and maybe
no i would never do that but it might i
was like this might be an option
and so but but this tactic of calling
these people it's been very helpful
so i'll give another i'm going to say
two things one on the thing we're
talking about earlier all right so this
is my uh
why it's okay to be douchey disclaimer
when when me and sam are like
oh we're doing this thing it's actually
been easier like we did this and it just
worked and i did five things that worked
and sam's like yeah maybe you could do
something easier i'm like i make it look
easy
i say that for three reasons number one
it's honest if something is easy i'll
tell you it's easy if something's hard
i'll tell you it's hard i'm not going to
like
say what it's not just because it sounds
better or worse and also it's the first
time when we say easy it can mean simple
like it's not actually easy but it's
like straightforward intellectually i
know how to do it i just have to put the
effort in it's also like um
for my personal trainer if he sits down
on a bench and there's like i don't know
whatever 200 pounds and he could he
could bench it it's easy for him because
he's put in 15 years of hard work so
that that is now easy for him and
similarly
i got my ass kicked for like nine
straight years from the age of like 20
to 29 with a startup failing over and
over and over again nothing could have
felt harder during that period of time
and so that now things are
relative like i don't relatively feel
much easier because i'm better now than
i was three four five years ago uh when
i kind of sucked
um so that's a that's the first part the
second reason uh that we say it's easy
is because this is a podcast and we're
trying to be entertaining the third
reason that we say it
or at least that i say it is
i am tired of everybody telling
everybody that like [__] is so hard and
like
if you go anywhere on the internet right
like we joke about the the
multi-trillionaire mindset like all of
the like entrepreneurship content
is like how hard it is you know uh elon
musk says
starting a company is like chewing glass
and looking into the abyss
some companies maybe
yeah maybe for you bro but like you know
i i do a power writing course it's fine
it's like chewing bubble gum and looking
at the pool like you know it's not the
same thing so
so it's not if if you always hear how
hard it is you kind of have to question
the source why do they say that hey it
makes them look more heroic b it keeps
other people from doing it c it kind of
justifies why i got like why i get to be
successful enrich because i'm paying
this huge cost and like
i actually subscribe to a different
version of entrepreneurship which is the
way that me and a lot of our friends do
things which is like we do it because
it's fun
it's just like it's genuinely fun to do
so it's not like this painful slog
um that doesn't mean it's like no effort
no it's pretty high effort just like
playing a game or playing like pick up
basketball you're gonna end up really
sweaty and tired by the end but nobody
confuses pick up basketball with like
digging in a sand mine to like you know
provide for your kids so it's like you
know there's a difference between like
uh enjoyable effort and painful effort
and i would say that for us what we do
is enjoyable effort and so i think it's
important for people to hear that not
everything has to be hard and slow and
painful like there is a version of doing
a business that is fun and faster and um
and you know enjoyable
and i just want to present both like
that both exist so that you don't like
pretend you don't create this fictional
story in your mind that like everything
has to be hard okay that's my disclaimer
did we uh cross the douche line hard
for sure
whatever
i'm a habitual uh line stepper
[Laughter]
the thing i forgot to say by the way the
reason the whole reason i went on that
tangent about i make it look easy with
the with the talking public speaking
thing was
the video i watched was from
toastmasters which i find to be a very
fascinating business
um and so i don't know if you know much
about toastmasters i only know a tiny
bit like i don't even entirely know what
it is it's like a it's an entity it's
like a group of meetups what is it ben
jonathan have you guys ever gone to
toastmasters do you have any experience
with this do you know anything about
toastmasters
i i know what it is but no i've never
been i have no experience with it how
would you explain in your words if sam
doesn't really fully know uh
i think of it as a public speaking group
where people who maybe don't feel
comfortable public speaking go and they
give little speeches to each other so
they can get comfortable with it and
learn more about public speaking and
jonathan did you have something yeah i
would say it's like people who wear
oversized suits who've been doing it for
years or people like me who probably
went when i was like
you know 15
and was just like trying to like get
better at talking to girls or whatever
the oversight suit thing is so spot-on
you can't watch a video of this and be
like ah
36 long you sure
that was not sure that was the right
member
i'm excited you know what that means i
mean you don't even own a suit
i don't but i just like you know i watch
tv or something so um so toastmasters is
this old school thing it gets around
like the one of the biggest fears people
have which is public speaking one of the
biggest desires is to be able to be a
good public speaker or be comfortable
speaking to strangers and so
toastmasters these like look it's like
alcoholics anonymous in a way it's like
these local franchises local meetups run
by local chairs and you go to the actual
place i think there's at least how
this is the picture i have in my mind my
mind of it you go to the place and they
kind of like teach you things but then
you also get practice in this kind of
safe space with a bunch of other people
who are trying to get good at this it's
very very useful it's been around for
like 20 years and there's like there's
like a whole like ecosystem of people
who really care about toastmasters
i think you could reinvent toastmasters
um like i feel like this is a business i
could start if i wanted to which is like
toastmasters i think can be
modernized like you don't have to have
the oversized suit you don't need the
like in-person meetups like i wrote
discord toastmasters like i think you
could do this whole thing and zoom or
discord
like i think you just have people get
into little chapters
practice this stuff make you know they
kind of meet people that kind of learn
some techniques and they kind of get
over their stage fright around public
speaking and the local ones ladder up
into like the state ones they ladder up
into like the national ones and some
people compete at it um and you get your
certificate after going through the
program and it's like kind of a course
it's kind of a church and it's kind of
like a self-help seminar um
that i think could be recreated in a
modern way using discord that's my idea
react to that you want to know something
interesting so toastmasters is a
non-profit so all their revenue is
public guess how much revenue they do
um i'm going to say 20 million a year
wow not far 36 it looks like 36 million
dollars a year in revenue um and it's
from membership dues and fees so it's
like a subscription revenue wow what do
they charge
and they've got 63 million dollars in
the bank it looks like
wow
let me manage that for you um
i could uh would you like to walk away
with half that but with a great story to
tell because i do have some crypto
investments for you
i agree with you i think that
i think it could work um how many
members do you think they have
i bet it's a huge number that pay a tiny
amount i feel like they have like
lifetime like
30 000 or 50 000 members of toastmasters
is that real or is that overkill i can't
find it on their thing but uh i can't
find it on their
my favorite type of pop quiz
[Laughter]
i don't know
i don't know how many members they have
but
i i'm on board i think this is really
interesting it's dude google have you
seen their logo
if you think if you think of a villain
from batman that's what their logo looks
like it's like a really old school
yeah like a corporate international
yeah
what the game should be
headquarters inc in uh it like
it's a clip art globe with like a blue
clip clipart globe with like you know
the the corporate name wrapped around
the globe wow this is this is an in this
is interesting i hadn't looked at this
in a minute um yeah i mean i'm aboard i
when i've gone i've gone to these before
they are
pretty life-changing i think learning
how to public speak i always tell people
this is the only
class i took in college that had an
impact on my life was uh like debate or
speech class or something whatever it
was called but that's like the only
class i think that actually matters that
i took in college so i think it's i
think these things are life-changing
yeah if somebody's working on this reach
out to me uh
i just want to know about it uh
specifically do not reach out to me if
you're like i'd love to talk to you
about potentially i might work on this
don't do that if you do it tell me and
just show me a link to your thing and
then let's not do a call but i'll check
it out and then let's talk more that's
my uh that's how i'd like to do this
going forward because i get a bunch of
inbound every time i say that it's like
not the right type i'll give you the
right type i talked about oh it'd be fun
to create a company like pixar like
maybe that's what i'll do i feel like i
could that would be amazing and it would
be so much fun
darmesh liked that
yeah i like what you're about to say you
got all hot and bothered is that where
you're going to
did you see uh someone goes uh
damn darmesh came on the pod i talked
about like how he's not worried about
losing 500 million dollars that's some
real big dick energy and he replied i
forget what he said he goes that's very
nice of you to say that i've got bde but
i i really think it's more like uh i've
got i i i try not to have that energy
but i try to have sev small ego what was
it vibes
small ego vibes and i replied uh that's
such a big dick energy thing to say
and he loved it and
sarah was like uh sarah was like
man darmesh is such a great guy but does
he know that he's like he needs to tell
you to shut the [__] up because uh he
needs to like put you down right now
because he's so nice that he just like
puts up with all this [__]
no it's great in fact your um hubspot
experience is i feel like the opposite
of my twitch experience like you got
acquired and i feel like they're like
go on cowboy do your thing out there and
like you know they love it and they're
like oh sam you know
vaguely you know offended you know one
tenth of the population today ah what a
guy that's all good
just you know he's doing his thing like
and they like engaged they like the
podcast all the stuff where i was like i
feel like when i was doing this stuff at
twitch they were like um does this guy
work here like why is he just on twitter
and like he just leaves in the middle of
day and goes and records at a studio and
like
what does it have to do with anything
that we do here and i feel like
my twitter personality was like a
constant source of annoyance for like
seventy percent of like the management
team there and thirty percent i think
liked it or appreciated it like the
sakura people they were just like oh
it's cool yeah do your thing man it's
cool i like it uh or like the thing you
said was stupid here's why it was stupid
and we get into a debate about it it was
all good but i feel like 70 percent of
people were just like silently like
f this guy this guy is no good well what
would you have done with you
it depends you know um
that's a great question that's a really
great question because my honest answer
is i would have been like
look man i get it uh i like what you do
i'm like basically i like what you're
doing
but i also feel like it's just kind of
selfish like you know you're doing your
thing it doesn't really have to do with
this so there's kind of like two ways
that this can go number one
if you're one foot out the door
let's maybe go two feet out the door
like maybe it'll save us both some pain
like if that's actually what you want to
do let's do it and like then i won't
feel like you know i don't want to ever
feel like you're not like kicking ass
for us um while that was the agreement
let's change the agreement if the
agreement needs to be changed
the second would be
the second way i'd approach it is look i
get it and this is what emmitt did tell
me he goes i get it you're not gonna be
here forever i win i wish that you
stayed forever but i i know your future
is not gonna be here um so let's be
honest about that that's fine uh he goes
he said to me he goes
when you do start your next thing i
would love to invest in it like because
i know you're not gonna be here forever
but i like i really like seeing how you
work i would invest you that that made
me feel awesome it made me really
respect the guy it made me like
put down my guard in terms of that like
okay i could just be honest with this
person which i think is just a great way
to like manage somebody and then the
last part i think that i would have kind
of tweaked is just like
um
let's agree
that
while you're here you're gonna kick ass
in these ways and here's my deal to you
you kick ass in these ways
um you do all these things but as soon
as you stop kicking ass then let's have
a conversation about why that happened
because i know that if you tried you
would do well that means if you're not
doing well that means you've stopped
trying and i'm not cool with stopping
trying like i'm cool if you're gonna
spend x percent of your energy doing
this other stuff and kind of paving your
future but
i need to know that at least you're
gonna kick ass when you're when you are
here i need you to be fully plugged in
when you are here
i mean part of the reason was also that
your like company had nothing to do with
necessarily the stuff that intrigued you
and interested you
uh my company in my job after the sale
was to create content and that's what
i'm doing and for the most part i do it
consistently like we're incredibly
consistent and mostly
rarely offend people and also
darmash is cool as [__] so of course i'm
gonna give him a hard time like like i
guess i'm gonna mess around with them
but everything we say is like flattering
for for him i at least i think it is
it's supposed to be but uh yeah that's
the big difference your job is to build
this podcast my job was to do something
else i was building the podcast as a
side thing like basically i would what i
would do is we record these at noon
because that's when everybody else at
twitch goes to the cafeteria to eat
lunch that's when the cafeteria opens
and i would just walk outside your
office was right across the street and
we built the studio there and i would
just walk across the street and instead
of eating lunch i would go do the
podcast and then when i got back i would
grab a bite and like take it to my desk
and like so that's how i kind of like
did it on the side whereas your job is
to do this thing which is quite
different
ben um
are is the audience gonna get any type
of value from this total meandering
um 12 year old discussion
don't do that you're just fishing for
him to say
we sucked right ben or maybe we do maybe
it's okay no ben give us the
full honest take don't don't don't
compliment sam because he put himself
down
so i'll i'll give you i'll give you a
backhanded compliment here's the
backhand i love those
this was a good episode
but they're the only fans for this
really i'm
um this was a good episode it was a good
episode because the show was about
business ideas
and the show was like very fun and great
but sometimes like get away from that
too much and this had numerous good
business ideas so like
the toastmasters uh of the future the
whatever discord meets toastmasters like
there's like an actually good business
idea that someone could run with or like
ddc soda stream like again it's like a
good business idea so
um
agency that's another one remixer agency
um kind of
uh tweets
uh as a service is not like a business
idea for someone else but like kind of
could spark some thoughts so it had a
ton as packed with business ideas so i
think it's a good episode
ben you also said it was backhanded but
then you just gave us a normal for
front-handed compliments
because i was saying like sometimes on
recent episodes
we don't talk a lot about business ideas
okay
that's why this one was good yeah okay
look we're getting back to it if you got
three
interesting business ideas out of this
podcast
i will put that up against any other
podcast you listen to how many podcasts
are giving you one good business idea
per hour
i'm dropping three
with at least four to five jokes solid
chuckles that will make you know the
person next to you on the bus be like
what are you listening to what is that
so i mean this podcast was phenomenal as
far as i'm concerned
hey before we go we did like a whole
deep dive on my dm history with uh mr
beast sean are we gonna talk about uh
yours at all yeah you know i was gonna
start the pod with this but i didn't
want to
you know like i don't know what the
etiquette is on is there a dialogue
going on outing sam parr as the only
person on this podcast that is not
friends
[Laughter]
and like you know i know that for some
people it's like it's your choice it's
your body your choice you want to
disclose that sam
now that we're here
after we recorded the pod about ben
getting a call from a dm and call from
mr beast
that episode's not even out yet
i checked my dm's yesterday
look who's here
mr beast and he's talking about
something else and i just thought to
myself i was pretty happy that it was mr
beast but i was only more happy that i
thought oh my god this means sam is the
only one of us that didn't get one and i
got i was over the moon so um
is there is there a dialogue going on
there's the dialogue bro this i'm saying
words he's saying words i'm sending
memes he's sending beams actually it's
just me sending the memes but i'm trying
to get a laugh
and uh yeah it's happening we are
full-fledged
hot and heavy conversation
i hate you mr beast good i don't want to
talk to you
and ben don't tell me if you told him to
dm me
like just don't tell me that i need to
feel like i did this
but i'm gonna put earmuffs on and you
say if you told him well
bent
i i told him listen there's these cool
guys that i mentor who i i help out
every now and then and uh you should i
think they would really like it it would
like make their lives if you could reach
out and like maybe tell them happy
birthday or something like that i think
that's why he reached out like a
make-a-wish foundation yeah
i do with these two guys they're a
little off
but they're like you mean the world to
you to them
if you would just accidentally you know
send him a word
do you uh
can we get him on here you think
i brought it up
he didn't bite the first time i brought
it up but now that shawn's dming with
him i bet i bet it does happen at some
point well ben you got a little kid you
know when you feed a kid they don't
always bite
but if they don't spit it out either
we say okay
tomorrow the airplane's coming in again
with the mac and cheese and we'll try
again tomorrow i don't know where we go
all right i guess that's it
[Music]
you